pendant des années mes parents m'ont
appelé parce que l'ordinateur
y planter il était devenu inutilisable
bon je sais pas ils ont dû penser à ma
place que c'était devenu ma grande
passion de passer mais week-end complet
à des plantes et des windows
complètement vérolé alors au bout d'un
moment j'en ai eu marre je les ai mis
sous linux
mon père a râlé world of warcraft ma
mère elle joue aux sims tout d'un coup
c'était magique
il pouvait ouvrir tous les pièces
jointes word powerpoint qui recevait par
email aucun virus n'arrivait à
s'installer dessus mais croyez-vous que
cela suffit non bien sûr
il fallait aussi leur expliquer les
règles de base de l'hygiène numérique qu
en piratant un ordinateur ou un compte
sur un serveur sur internet on peut
vider votre compte en banque
on peut aussi contracté un prêt à votre
place on peut rançonner les données
auxquels vous tenez particulièrement et
on peut aussi tenter d'escroquer vos
amis les plus chers en se faisant passer
pour vous comme j'étais souvent
sollicité pour ces problématiques là le
concept de crypto parti qui est apparue
en 2012 tombé à pic dans une crypte au
parti des gens qui connaissent
l'informatique rencontre le très grand
public pour leur expliquer comment
marche un ordinateur comment est
construit internet
qu'est ce que la vie privée et comment
la protéger
une des règles par exemple et de ne pas
installer n'importe quel programme sur
son ordinateur ou son smartphone
pourquoi on connaît pas vraiment
finalement les intentions de la personne
qui nous le fournit peut-être souhaite
elle récupérer un maximum d'informations
sur vous et les revendre à quelqu'un
d'autre
oui un programme c'est comme un bonbon
d'un inconnu on n'accepte pas
heureusement il ya un règlement européen
qui va être mise en oeuvre en mai 2018
qui va fortement moraliser l'industrie
de la donner en certes ça ne va pas tout
faire ça concernera principalement les
entreprises européennes et celles qui
ont une représentation en europe mais
cela va nous faciliter fortement pour
expliquer au grand public ce que c'est
que la vie privée mais disons que vous
installez pas n'importe quel programme
soit mai
prenons votre tablette que vous avez
acheté il ya deux ans est-ce que son
fabricant fournit encore des mises à
jour dessus ou le baby phone vous savez
la caméra connecter sur internet qui
diffuse en permanence qui se passe dans
la chambre de bébé vous avez installé
est ce que vous êtes sûre qu'elle n'a
pas été conçu à l'économie et qu'elle
n'est pas pire attaque par n'importe qui
il se trouve que l'an dernier des
groupes criminels ont réussi à prendre
le contrôle de centaines de milliers de
caméras de surveillance connecter sur
internet et avec toute cette puissance
ils sont attaqués à de grandes
entreprises rendant certaines d'entre
elles inutilisable pendant plusieurs
heures voire plusieurs jours
c'est pour ça qu'il est important de
faire pression sur les fabricants et de
leur demander à ce qu'il fasse les
maintenances sur le moyen et sur le long
terme
ce n'est pas qu'une question de leur
sécurité informatique c'est aussi une
question d'écologie
ça veut dire qu'on ne va pas jeter un
appareil au bout d'un an parce qu'il est
devenu inutilisable parce qu'il a été
piraté malheureusement notre vie privée
des fois traiter vraiment à la légère
pardon excusez moi est un chouette
publique mais dans une très belle salle
je me permets je rêve d'une banque qui
protège vraiment mon argent d'une bande
qui réfléchit à deux fois avant de me
proposer un service pas d'une banque qui
veut imposer le paiement sans contact
non ça j'en veux pas pourquoi l'an
dernier en angleterre 8 millions d'euros
ont été détournés par ce moyen de
paiement
c'est un triplement par rapport à
l'année précédente en fait ce chiffre il
est fortement sous-évaluée parce qu'on
ne pense pas à porter plainte pour une
petite somme
heureusement en un moyen de pression il
est financier
si on n'achète pas un service parce
qu'il est objectivement mauvais il ne se
vend pas et donc le fabricant ira revoir
sa copie mais bon disons que vous faites
attention à ce que vous achetez fait
attention à ce que vous installez fait
attention à effectuer la mise à jour
pensé d'ailleurs à faire la mise à jour
aussi de vos voitures connectées télé
connectée et tout le reste d'avoir un
mot de passe solide de ne pas donner
n'importe quelle information sur
internet
mais que se passe-t-il dans un service
de renseignement découvre une faille de
sécurité et ne communique pas dessus
qu'on ce même service de renseignement
va voir un fabricant et lui demande
d'installer une porte dérobée dans ses
produits pour raison d'état et qu'avec
ses failles de sécurité ce service de
renseignement construisent des logiciels
qu'on appelle des seins nus mairie afin
de pouvoir éventuellement attaqué des
méchants ennemis ce service de
renseignement va stocker ces outils
quelque part et malheureusement ce
l'effet voulait se fait pirater et ses
armes se retrouvent aux mains de
criminels c'est la sf
non pas vraiment c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé en mai dernier avec le verbe
and cry
la nasa était parfaitement au courant
d'une faille de sécurité critique et n'a
pas prévenu les fabricants afin qu'il
puisse corriger ce problème au plus vite
et donc ils ont laissé s'infecter des
millions d'ordinateurs
comme ça par pure négligence est
peut-être temps de faire pression sur
nos élus politiques et leur dire que on
pourrait faire attention à ça que la
lutte contre le terrorisme ne doit pas
excusé n'importe quoi et qu'on ne veut
pas non plus que nos outils servent à ça
mais d'où ça vient en fait cette
histoire c'est bien ce monsieur michael
rogers
le directeur de la msa en 2001 c est lui
avec son sourire instruments jeu en
jouent leur qui a fait que nos
ordinateurs et nos smartphones sont
devenus les mouchards des fantasmes
aurait révélé la gestapo et la stasi est
en fait en portant ce costume
j'essaie d'interpeller les gens et
j'essaie de leur faire comprendre que la
lutte contre le terrorisme ne doit pas
justifier d'une lutte contre nantes vie
privée ces gens là ont déclaré la guerre
à nous tous les citoyens d'internet
il est temps pour nous de dire stop ne
transformait pas les outils du numérique
on sert tous les jours en armes contre
nos libertés individuelles
il est temps qu'on ôte génération
d'obtenir que la cnil retrouve la
mission pour laquelle elle a été fondée
initialement en 1978 protéger l'ensemble
des citoyens contre le fichage abusif
par l'état et d'ailleurs il serait temps
de demander à notre gouvernement de
demander des comptes envers les autres
états qui pratiquent la surveillance
globale vis-à-vis de nous et quelle que
soit d'ailleurs cet état il serait temps
aussi d'accueillir et d'écouter les
vrais spécialistes sur le sujet comme
edward snowdon
ça ne devrait pas être difficile il
parle français
or à dire tout ça je dois être
pessimiste mais en fait pas du tout moi
je suis persuadé qu'on peut vivre une
transition vers une société du numérique
en toute confiance qu'on peut aller vers
un futur qui soit riant libre créatif
pas vers une dictature dystopique ou en
fait on a peur de penser je suis
persuadé qu'on peut continuer à
communiquer en toute confidentialité
avec nos proches et si vous voulez en
savoir plus venez aux cryptes au parti
si vous savez tout ça venez au critt au
parti et créer les ans
[Applaudissements]